[Música]
yo pienso el que formuló deja en picado
en esta causa hace mucho tiempo y cuando
vimos de que esta muchacha en suecia
comenzó un movimiento tan grande como
todos los viernes también te falta la
escuela para hacer una manifestación
para manifestar pensamos de que era una
buena idea de que nosotros pudiéramos
implicarnos en este movimiento los
jóvenes como es el futuro y que si
nosotros nos comenzamos este movimiento
que no va a comenzar
lo importante y yo pienso es de que
queremos que tenga conciencia lo que
hace en el medio ambiente que merece es
la base de todo
el medio ambiente no tenemos nada
estamos viendo al gobierno de que tengan
nuevas leyes para proteger el medio
ambiente y que las leyes se cumplan
porque siempre dicen de que van a hacer
algo pero nunca lo hacen que prefieren
que las lleguen otras partes como el
espectro leo siempre ponen plata donde
no hay pero no en el medio ambiente
nunca le ponen
y queremos que él haga un programa donde
la gente comprenda que debe hacer para
ayudar el medio ambiente
una participación ciudadana